on sera rendu public merci la parole est
à monsieur laurent furst monsieur le
ministre des collectivités territoriales
avant de vous poser ma question je
voudrais rendre ici hommage à tous les
députés maires qui vont disparaître dans
15 jours lorsque la session
parlementaire pendant la fin c'est une
page d'histoire de la république qui va
se tourner ce sera aussi j'en suis
persuadé une moins value pour la qualité
du travail parlementaire
je voudrais citer ici un ancien député
maire françois hollande dans la
proposition 54 de son projet il
promettait qu'un pacte de confiance
serait conclu entre l'état et les
collectivités garantissant des dotations
à leur niveau de 2012 s'il ya une
promesse qui n'aura pas été tenues c'est
bien celle-là car au final vous aurez
imposées aux collectivités une véritable
purge budgétaire qui s'est traduite par
un effondrement de leurs investissements
tout dotation confondues de 2013 à 2017
la baisse des concours de l'état aura
été de 20,7 pour cent
monsieur le ministre vous êtes un
remarquable illusionniste alors que des
deux mains vous étrangler les
collectivités notamment les communes
vous avait abondé les dotations des
notaires exil d'un côté vous prélevez
sens de l'autre vous rendez 20 et à
force d'insister vous fait croire qu'on
en a jamais fait autant pour les
territoires ruraux
mes chers collègues il ya pire encore ce
sont désormais les sous préfets et les
préfectures qui attribue des subventions
vital à des collectivités en apnée
financière la liberté des communes
consiste désormais à quémander des
subventions auprès des services de
l'état qui crée ainsi un lien de
dépendance
monsieur le ministre pour les
collectivités locales
le volet financier du quinquennat de
françois hollande est dramatique et
demain il n'y aura plus de mer dans
cette assemblée pour défendre les
communes de france parce qu'elles sont
au coeur de notre démocratie
cela est plus mais rassembler mis la
parole est à mme adam metz tél
grelier secrétaire d'état chargé des
collectivités territoriales
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le député furieuse elle est très
audacieuse votre question monsieur le
député et elle ne manque pas d'un
certain culot parce que comme vous le
savez le candidat aux élections
présidentielles que vous soutenez
propose un plan d'austérité de 100
milliards d'euros je parle là un
spécialiste 100 milliards d'euros ça
revient à supprimer l'allocation de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
forfaitaire pour toutes les communes à
cela il ajoute la suppression de
nombreux postes de fonctionnaires
territoriaux en contravention totale
monsieur le député avec le principe de
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales et cet article de presse
qui retraçait cette interview de
monsieur fillon dans lesquelles il
préconisait de manière autoritaire la
suppression de trente mille communes
devraient vous amener à poser vos
questions sur un autre temps à d'un
autre ton et avec un peu plus de
modestie nous avons fait participer les
collectivités monsieur le député à
l'effort de redressement des comptes
publics de la nation mais comme vous le
savez cet effort s'est accompagnée d'un
renforcement inédit de la péréquation
sur la dotation de solidarité rurale je
crois que vous l'avez vous même voter
sur la dotation de solidarité urbaine
sans compter le fonds de péréquation
intercommunale et communale à hauteur de
1 million d'euros et nous avons
renforcer l'investissement local un
milliard de fonds de soutien à
l'investissement local dont un milliard
de dhs et aux terres et quant à votre
remarque sur la gestion déconcentrée des
fonds c'est une demande des maires eux
mêmes d'avoir une gestion déconcentrée
de ces fonds pour éviter de répondre à
des appels à projets avec leurs sous
préfet qui connaissent particulièrement
bien la situation alors vous voyez votre
critique est absolument exagérés et nous
avons fait pour ces collectivités
une réforme territoriale structurelles
et irait verte